[Music]
when we want to change people's behavior
we often say do this don't do that right
basically we are a lot of times giving
orders whether it is to our kids people
in our family people that we work it
with we are exerting control over others
or at least attempting to exert control
over others but what we find is that
what the brain is trying to do it's
trying to control its environment that's
one of the the major goals of what the
brain is trying to do and it's trying to
do that in order to get rewards and
avoid losses and because of that in the
brain control has been associated with
something good with a reward and it's
something that people seek out if people
can make a choice the same part of the
brain that is activated when people get
a piece of food like a piece of
chocolate is activated when people have
an opportunity to make a choice when
people don't have an opportunity to make
a choice when they feel they don't have
control what is triggered is anxiety and
so what this means is that giving people
a choice giving people a sense that they
are in control that they have agency is
more likely to motivate them is more
likely to put them in the frame of a
reward rather than a loss and because
control in and of itself is rewarding a
lot of times people will be willing to
give up other kind of rewards like
monetary rewards in order to have
control for example in a study that I
conducted with my colleagues we gave
people the opportunity to either make
choices themselves about random shapes
that can give them rewards or give
another person an expert an opportunity
to make a choice for them and what we
found is that people stopped optimally
make the decision to have to keep the
agency to keep the choice themselves
rather than have an expert make the
choice for them even if the expert was
more likely to choose a
correct thing to choose a thing that
will get them more money so a way to
think about it it's a bit like the stock
market so a lot of people like to pick
their own stocks right instead of giving
someone else the opportunity to choose
for them experts so even better going
according to an index right and the
reason that people like to pick their
own stocks it because it gives them a
sense of control it gives them a sense
of agency and that gives them reward and
many times people realize that there
might be a monetary loss some people are
overconfidence they think well I'll pick
the right thing and that's fine but they
still are willing to lose parts to have
a monetary loss to make the choice
themselves so in fact in in general
people people prefer to make their own
choices but the there are incidents
where people would rather give away that
choice and for example when the choice
is so complicated the effort is so so
much effort has to be put in it that I
would rather not do it and give someone
else the opportunity to make the choice
for me or for example under high amounts
of stress people sometimes realize that
it's better to have someone else make
the choice for them or for example when
making a choice people are afraid that
they will regret what they choose such
as in medical decisions they sometimes
actually prefer to have someone else
make the choice for them and in the book
I talk about the things that people are
scared of the most
and the fears that we have are not
necessarily rational so people for
example are a lot of people are scared
of flying right so if you look at the
numbers flying is not necessarily the
most dangerous thing that you do driving
your own car is more dangerous but
people are afraid of flying because one
of the reasons is that once you're in
the plane you don't have control anymore
you don't have control over the plane
you don't have control of anything
really of your environment so the sense
of being in this space where you're
losing control completely giving it to
someone else is something that people
feel anxious about now they don't want
to take control I don't want to fly the
plane right I know I will be dead if
I'll slide the pain but nevertheless I
feel anxious and I think that's true in
other domains like health
one of the reasons that being in a
hospital is anxiety-provoking not only
because you're sick and that's very you
know anxiety floating but also because
again you lose control everyone's making
the decision for you as they should the
doctors and the nurses I mean people
should have some say but they realize
that the experts are making the choices
for them and that sense of losing
control again can cause anxiety and one
thing that studies have shown is that as
we age as we go into older age we lose
some of our control right especially if
we go to nursing homes other people make
the choices for us and that induces
stress on the individual as well because
no longer can I choose what will I do
and when will I do it and giving people
a sense of control back can help them
again with kids
people tell tend to tell kids exactly
what to do when to do it and so on and
there's a lot of you know kids are not
happy with that but we could change that
you know until instead of telling the
other kids well you have to eat your
salad maybe say oh why don't you create
your own salad here are the different
ingredient they're putting them together
create them and one study that we've
done shown that when people and it's not
only us we did one example of this
there's many many studies showing that
that when you create something you value
it more so we did a study where people
created their own converse shoes and
they liked a converse shoes that they
created much more than a Congress shoes
which looked exactly the same that
someone else created the same colors the
same shape everything was exactly the
same but if I created it I liked it more
moreover even if I didn't create it but
I thought I created it I believed I
created I wrongly had a memory that I
created the shoe I liked it better so if
you feel like you had agency and
something in whether it's a product
whether it's an idea then you feel like
it's worth more and it doesn't actually
have to be a true perception you just
have to have a perception of an agency
the perception of a control in order to
value that thing
and that's what we've shown in our study
looking at how people create shoes and
how they value them
[Music]